let me ask you something personal and if
I'm digging too deep you tell me you
know you can't oh God no no no no this
is personal stuff when you were in here
the last time you were telling me your
father was a not a good guy right no he
he was a good guy he was he he was a did
he abandon you he was a broken guy yeah
but he abandoned you yes he did and your
father died uh since I last saw you yes
right last year do you go to the funeral
oh yeah you did oh sure but were you
guys talking at the end oh yeah oh you
were yeah we reconciled oh when did you
reconcile oh I got back in touch with
him when I was 22 or 23 years old what
was that like it was awkward yeah
um but we were curious my brother and I
were curious about who he was and where
he went and what was going on and once
you reconcile the relationship was good
it was what it became it was you know of
his generation he wasn't the type of
person who would uh freely go into
therap therapy and to talk about things
it's like no so he couldn't discuss what
did you was going on and what happened
to you as a result no did you ever say
to him dad
didn't you love me weren't you curious
about me didn't didn't right you just
wondering where's my son like did you
ever say did you ever think about me or
do you just don't even bring that up not
specifically that I didn't want to get
that I would be in a more General sense
like was there a thought of why you you
could divorce someone but to Desert your
children you know was there and he said
he was in a extremely bad place right
there was uh not only you know a massive
mid-life crisis but there was alcohol
and drug abuse I think so did you
definitely absolutely he did did you
have a conversation with him on his
deathbed or anything like that where you
kind of just had a heart to heart and a
connection no but what's really sad is
that he had a pacemaker put in he was 90
right when he passed and this is last
October
and my we're going through his things
afterward and my daughter found on a
just a piece of paper like you know they
pulled off and tore off a piece of paper
and in his shaky handwriting he wrote
the the happiest day of my life is when
my children forgave me for the worst
period of my life Wow